we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we one of
the frequent david pakman show bingo
terms that some people pay attention to
is related to me mentioning that I
worked at Circuit City when I was in
high school in college and the AG man
claims to have one sir david pakman show
bingo on the basis of me recently
mentioning Circuit City on the bonus
show take a listen bingo
hey Dave so every we made those david
pakman bingo cards and you put down
phrases that Dave would say you know
we'll have to delete this one will edit
this out you know that every podcaster
says every time dave says this right
well one of the things that my bingo
card was Circuit City or when I worked
at Circuit City and I've been waiting to
put another one of those ever since and
you just hit me it so I just got bingo
Oh Dave Sal oh brother I love you yeah
you know I actually don't think I
mentioned Circuit City that often most
people still when I look at comments are
very surprised that I ever worked at
Circuit City but I did and I was in the
president's Club I was one of the top
salespeople at Circuit City and I got a
free trip to Orlando Florida that's it's
actually a true story it wasn't the best
trip I will admit but it was a trip
nonetheless on today's bonus show we
will talk about a new report related to
urban congestion pricing it turns out
that people who live in cities that
implement congestion pricing don't like
it but then they get over it very
quickly and it actually does help deal
with congestion we will also talk about
a Texas bartender who has been charged
for serving a gunman before that gunman
went on a mass shooting and it is a very
interesting case from a legal
perspective we'll also just talk about
the kind of common-sense elements of it
and in Rhode Island students who Oh
lunch money will get only jelly
sandwiches until their debt is paid we
will talk about that new policy and much
more get instant access not delayed
access instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at david pakman.com
slash membership or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show